so thanks a lot good afternoon is a
pleasure to be here today and we're very
excited to introduce a new technology
that we develop in the past twelve
months using javascript nodejs and some
module with Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
connectivity that allow us to have the
IOT connected with the JavaScript I just
make a quick introduction about myself
my name is federico and i'm running a
global startup naming dog hunter and the
little guys over there on the mountain
and with my two daughters and we have a
global startup base in u.s. Taipei and
Switzerland and we build the Wi-Fi
modules we are here today to explain a
little bit about our open source project
named Lonnie no the the philosophy
behind the line Ino project is basically
to bring the Acre community and the
maker community all together so we are
building a gateway that allow the
hackers that write apps on the web to
talk with the makers community that
usually write software for the real
things which light controllers stuff
like that so what is lenino lenino is an
open-source project based on an
ecosystem so we build the hardware
without the Wi-Fi and Bluetooth modules
we write the open software that allow us
to use JavaScript to interact with the
microcontroller and we write also the
open cloud software that allow
the user to interact with the cloud we
call this project line II know we have
lightning os lightning or IT sorry
lightning IO and lightning no J yes and
we call that Linux for IOT so what we
are trying to do we build a server
module server hardware that one of the
module is the Chihuahua that is
basically small I will show you later a
small module with Linux built in and we
build this module in any devices that
has an MCU so basically we bring the
powerful Linux inside the MCU as you can
see here we have a full Linux OS with
package manager Wi-Fi connectivity and
we built this module inside of optimal
MCU freescale MCU as the MSU and any
generic MCU and we transform these dump
devices in something that we call smart
devices connected all together with
Wi-Fi Bluetooth so how we do that the
the classic approach is basically to
write code for the MCU and then to find
the library or gateway that allows you
the Linux to talk with MCU we build
something different we basically took
the MCU directly inside the Linux part
and then all the features of them's you
that should be analog devices GPIO PWM s
where CSPI
are part of the Linux part so basically
they are hold together in just one core
so what we are able to do here is to
keep the mpu for patchy for JavaScript
no GS and still use the MCU for the
real-time application and we do that not
only on the
the space but also in the wireless so in
other way any module that is connected
on our network export the features on
the Linux OS and we are able to see all
these features just on the file system
so basically we can control devices just
that's a very simple example that I have
here using a potentiometer or switch ON
switch off and basically what happened
when I use these devices
everything is on file system so I can
see the results of my devices directly
on the file system the sample that I'm
here I can change the PWM value just
changing a value on the file system can
see the sysclass MCU PWM and then I
change the value I can do the same with
ADC and I could do the same with the
GPIO in the the classical application
what you have to do is you you have to
write your application and MCU you need
to write your application the Linux and
then you need to use some API some
bridge to talk together with this
solution you don't have to do that but
just to use the file system so whatever
happened on the MCU will be export on
this file system here so we build a
bunch of hardware modules that have
already this technology one very famous
is that we know you that is probably I
don't know which one no this product we
build this module last September and as
you can see we build basically a names
you from up the Atmel and we build the
linux part and we bring all together
we have other modules like the something
we call lightning a one but is basically
the same stuff that we did without you
know UHN but just in different form
factor is a breathable so something that
you can stick on the breadboard we build
also some shoe some module LJ module we
call Chihuahua that is for mass
production is a basically the same thing
that you can use without yuna you know
line you know one but it's a small
little teeny
that you can bring on your project and
then we have a some other module that
are available today two point four and
five iron foggy guards we have a
Freescale MCU because of the very
important part that we build this
technology as a cross platform a
technology so we can use in basically an
atmel MCU on a freescale MCU and then
you've MCU that you are working right
now and of course we also build some
shield so with the sensor that allows
you to control stuff so let me talk a
little bit about software modules and
they talked a little bit about the
OpenStack and then show you some sample
that we had we did and we are able to
show you in the backstage so basically
we have two modules at the hardware that
is the Linux part and then the MCU part
in this sample here we have an empty mix
MCU where we have our Linux up and
running and then we have the line in Rio
that this is not a small an operating
system that is up and running on MCU and
we are able to export all the feature
directly on the filesystem of the Linux
machine doesn't matter if this Linux
machine is on my desk or is somewhere
else like Boston Chicago I'm able to
control everything as an active
application on my desk
so this delaney no operating system we
are using right now open wrt and we
build in top of that aligning Ayoo using
the Linux kernel modules and on top of
that we have a tennouji yes for them
better development or we can use just
the shell scripting Java the Python and
of course in top of everything we have
the application wrote in JavaScript for
mobile application or cloud applications
to to keep everything simple we also
build a small IDE that run directly on
the module so you don't need any
external application
external tools you can use our IDE no
that is a small IDE that is built
directly inside the module and as you
can see you can definitely use no Jes to
write your javascript application as a
server label that is a screenshot of our
idea and we have the contextual menu the
file manager console the code editor
everything is open source that we think
is available directly inside the module
we made this a couple of slide now that
we are trying to show you a real
scenario so the first is a mood cube
basically the is a no GS and software
that we build inside the module we have
server module we bring one over here and
then we made another demo using a mobile
control so basically iPhone and
everything has been done using
javascript so let's show the first one
the first one uses one of our module
everything is of course open source open
hardware so we build our module but
someone else can make it and we put some
little switch that allow us to control
the motor the code that you need to
write on the North Valley si is the one
that you see here so basically we import
our library yes we connect to an another
port 0 Buttershaw meter and then we
basically use a callback to set the
digital nine to the service mode and
basically what happened when we turn the
switch on off we are able to move the
arrow that show us our mood I'm using a
small demo here I'm using ID no I write
my code I record my computer when
everything is done I start run and I
transfer the control over my little
CPU as you can see there is a
initialization procedure and then I move
the arrow directly with the switch and
everything is done directly on the board
so I don't need to use any any library
any breach
everything is done directly inside the
JavaScript environment as I'll show you
before we build another application a
little more complex that I would be
happy to show you in the backstage if
you want that basically control an LED
but very easy one is something that we
call the hello world for the MCU so in
that case we made a small application on
html5 using our library again is an open
source library that you can use on the
mobile control so in JavaScript and
jQuery and what we build inside the
small device inside the nodejs is this
five line of code as you can see we
import the Lightning a board object the
HTML board and then we enable the GPIO
with the very very easy
command as you can see here we are using
the tools in this case we're using Intel
XDK tool to be able to control over the
phone my device and the code that I have
to write on these tools is basically
what you can see here so some
initialization code and then event when
I press the button on my mo by and this
is a the demo again I'm using IDE the my
ide no inside the board throughout the
code i press one and they transfer the
control now to my mobile application
that would be able to control my device
the one that we're using right now is
like nino but we can use a lightning one
but we can use a they are doing a you
nor any other modules again it's an open
so we can put these codes to any other
Linux platform or should be ro tp-link
router whatever the software that user
now is a Intel XDK that allow us to have
an application for an iPhone in a very
easy way so we don't need to apply to
put our application in the Apple App
Store so that's why we use this so it's
an Intel XDK is towards a company that
has been recently acquired from Intel
and very easy stuff yeah
now this is very very simple application
you can say we saw that many many times
well the difference is that I don't need
to take care about the microcontroller
ID the only thing that you need to do is
write a JavaScript application that will
play with a file system of the Linux
file system can play as you can see on
the same desk but he can run remotely
the last part of our software structure
is the cloud and that is something that
we are going to announce in the next
week in New York in the maker faire and
basically we're building a system
provisioning platform that allow to have
a control over the cloud everything is
open source so you can eventually build
your own cloud to control your your
hardware the provisioning platform we
are working to build a special NPM a
library just for like Nino we are using
MIPS technology right now and sometime
we need to recompile the library and in
our small module we don't have the power
enough to do that so we're doing
directly in our servers we are working
to have an ecosystem that allow us to
take all this module connected all
together and of course we are building
we are bringing these technologies to
other devices Raspberry Pi Beagle bone
and the new board from Qualcomm or just
a recently one that has been announced
from Intel it is a one I don't know
for familiar with this was a very short
introduction I hope you enjoy I hope you
will if you have any question I would be
more than happy to show you in more
details what we are done and I just want
to say thank you for your time and your
patient today thank you so much